welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today
as we take your questions and you're
about life and about money open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five uh aaron is in
gainesville florida hi erin welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey dave and rachel i'm so glad i get to
talk to you guys this is great
honor to speak with you sir how can we
help awesome so i'm 23 years old and i'm
currently a graduate student
they pay for my tuition and everything
so i'm not taking on more debt
and i get paid twenty five thousand
dollars a year as a site
right 37 000 worth of debt um
from my undergrad and i do doordash on
the side sometimes too so i probably
made a little more than 25 last year
but anyways what are you studying
uh aerospace engineering good for you
well done
yeah yeah so um i
have to clarify i'm not completely
following your biscuit recipe to a tea
i have been trading in the markets over
the past few months and i'm
very lucky to say that as of this
morning
i profited forty seven thousand dollars
in gamestop
stock and i cashed out of it completely
um i currently have an ach transfer on
the way to my bank
and i love to wipe out that 37 000
worth of debt but i am a natural spender
and i've never seen this much money in
my life
so i'd like your advice on what to do
with the rest of it
so you don't follow my advice about
investing but you want my advice on what
to do with the money you made
when you got the luckiest hit of your
freaking life i suppose yeah
yeah i definitely agree with you it is
uh
how much did you invest to make 46 on
gamestop
it was about five thousand dollars i'm
so glad for you and i'm glad i'm really
glad you got out
i'm really glad you got out because it's
gonna it's the the guys are gonna take a
spanking on this before it's over but
uh because obviously obviously the
capitalization at this current rate is
not the
company's not worth anywhere near that
it's lost money for two years as you
know you know the story
so um but uh uh uh
yeah how much how many uh years left
erin do you have in grad school i'm just
curious
um i have it's about three three more
years and how are you and you got this
the this fellowship all the way through
with the stipend and everything
what's that you have the fellowship all
the way through you mean you have the
stipend and the
the scholarship all set up all the way
through yes
and there's a potential i get a raise
but uh it's dependent on a few factors
we'll see what happens
okay my normal answer
would be set the 46 000 aside let your
student loans lay there
to ensure that you finish grad school
without any debt
but with your misbehavior patterns
your tendency to spend and to gamble
um i'm probably going to just pay off
your student loans and that way it won't
get away from you
okay i mean
what i like to do is i like to look at
myself in the mirror and say these are
my weak spots
what what kind of system can i put in
place to offset my weak spots
and i just called yours out and the
system would be paying off the student
loans
so either one of those answers is going
to be fine
and you know you've got the same problem
that rachel had when she hit
good on the craps table uh she's
addicted you know i'm not addicted
i do love craps though oh yeah
so once once every three years people
yeah once every three years
but i mean you know and rachel's mom hit
with some quarters on the slot machine
one time on the
uh you know and made 50 bucks on the uh
on the cruise one time and it cost me
500 before she quit putting quarters in
there
so that's the problem that's the problem
you got because 78
of the day traders lose money and you
just got caught in uh
an iconic story and
and made bank i mean you made 10x i'm
really glad for you i mean i'm not
wishing bad things on you
because you can use this and like and in
a snap advance your future
financially i mean like you could be on
baby step four i mean you that because
use the rest
yeah to put in your emergency funds so
like look at this
game stop stock as taking you to baby
step four automatically yeah
and then that's it and then go back to
the old school okay we're gonna invest
we're gonna be wise over the long term
because that's what it is okay explain
it do the okay so
the deal is when you do day trading um
you 8 out of 10 people lose money
it's that simple it's a high risk play
it literally
is walking up to the craps table and
dropping four grand on there
five grand on there and you hit and you
walk away with forty six thousand
dollars
does that make that a good idea no
it does not just because you beat the
system one time
and the danger is when you beat the
system one time you think you've got the
recipe
i'm great at crafting and that's what i
believe yeah that's what you believe and
it's a roll of a dice nobody can be good
at it it's not even a skill game
so uh so there you go yeah hot hands
with the crowd
hold the dice yeah right yeah that's
yeah she see there you go
this is the problem with it right here
so what's happened with gamestop for
those of you that don't know there's a
group of guys
and gals on reddit that do some
investing some day trading
and uh gamestop is a is a game
company where you go and buy video games
physically walk into a store and buy a
video game
and uh most video games are now
downloaded
and so their business model is
blockbuster
after netflix came along they're screwed
and they've lost money the last two
years and they're projected to lose
money for the next two years
in other words they're projected to go
out of business their stock was trading
down around 20
and a bunch of big fat cats on wall
street started shorting the stock
which means taking a position betting
that the stock was going to go down
and they make money if it goes down
which is a pretty safe bet because the
thing is imploding
uh and the company's not even worth 20 a
share
in its current state and um so these you
know hedge fund
fat cats are doing this so these guys on
reddit which are kind of they're fun
they're they're a bunch of rebels
and they just they said we're going to
get together and screw over these hedge
fund guys
and so they all start buying gamestop
stock and run the price up
and they ran it up from twenty dollars
to five hundred dollars a share
which screwed the fat cats because that
short positions all those margin calls
came in
and they lost their butts probably lost
a billion dollars on it
uh the wall street fat cats and so these
young rebel rebel you know their little
reddit revolutionaries is what they are
they're fun but the
the uh you know and they some of them
have made some money this guy made money
made 26 000 way to go that's awesome but
i mean just because you hit it
you know you go into the market and you
take a lotto ticket and you scratch and
you make 50 grand
that does not make that an investment
strategy that means you were so lucky
that you know you beat all the
statistical odds and
you don't want that to be your
investment strategy so don't
follow this weird little moment in time
and make it your new your retirement
your new plan a wealth building plan
it's
you know how much money i put in
gamestop zero i know let's don't do this
stuff
let's talk about single stocks and stuff
when we come back though okay
just for questions yeah so anyway it's
kind of fun to watch the little guys
knock out the big fat cats and not
give but some of you little guys and amc
yeah they're messing with us from other
companies yeah mc's losing their butt
because movies are so
yesterday and so uh unbelievable
and yeah so guys like aaron got out in
time
you guys are still screwing around with
it you're gonna take a spanking if you
don't get out of there
they're going this thing's going to give
you a spanking it's coming this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and best-selling
author of the new book
know yourself know your money discover
why you handle money
the way you do and what to do about it
jump in and check that out it'll change
everything on the way you look at things
and that's very very important
so let's do continue that discussion we
don't usually do that many teaching
segments in a row but i think it's good
to do this because this is so such a hot
topic right now
the the gamestop stock but what it
illustrates
is whether it's the lotto
whether it's playing single stocks uh
whether it's
gambling and playing the roulette wheel
or craps or
whatever there's a thrill that comes
with the risk
that releases the dopamine and releases
the proteins and the enzymes into your
body
and it that's why gambling
is addictive yeah and uh uh
because there's literally a a you know a
flood of
it's adrenaline your body creates a
flood of drugs yeah
adrenaline and other things and physical
of a physical reaction in your body when
you're doing this
so these guys are having a rush right
now riding this little thing they've
created
they really are and it's it's not a
little thing it's a big thing i mean
they are they are doing this but what
you can't do
is confuse that get
rich quick thing with the mentality that
you know get rich quick or get rich easy
suddenly
without effort uh with an actual
plan to become wealthy because there's
no
evidence anywhere in any data
that shows that people starting from you
know
nothing like i did and becoming wealthy
did it using that mentality
the get cre rich quick mentality instead
it leads you to buy nothing down real
estate and you go broke yeah
me i did that okay or leads you to
play single stocks or day trade or
bitcoin or that's what's driving this
the the a lot of these things are
gambling um
playing you know gambling on football
games sports big
sports sports game gaming is a huge yep
mammoth industry now yep and it's all
the same thing i'm trying to find an
easy way to make a lot of money
quickly and the problem is that not only
the philosophy of that is bad the
theology that is bad
but there's no data to back up your plan
there's no one that does it and it works
out and that's what scares me
yes people put all their eggs in that
kind of basket right and they're
thinking oh if i could just
just figure this out it's all gonna be
good it's all gonna be okay and
the pattern shows over history it's not
like building well it's not gonna work
we say it all the time it's boring the
majority of millionaires in that study
that we did here
eight thousand millionaires or twelve
ten thousand millionaires
they were millionaires because they had
a paid for home
and a great 401k they've invested over
the long time over a long period of time
so like
none of them said they made it with
options puts calls
playing commodities right uh you know
and it's not as exciting but it's okay
so tell me this because people do ask a
lot
or ask me hey you know gosh i really i
kind of want to like get into single
stocks or
or i do i enjoy gambling is that okay
all that
here's my philosophy tell me if i'm
wrong when your mindset is hey
i am doing the plan i'm going to
continue to invest in my retirement like
my overall philosophy is this now if you
want to take
some money and think okay yeah i'm going
to vegas i want to gamble some
and having the mentality that that money
instead of buying a concert ticket or
instead of doing an experience
it comes out of your entertainment
envelope not your investment category
that's what i was going to say though is
that you have the
emotional capacity to say if this money
is gone it's fine because i'm just doing
it
for entertainment i'm not doing it to
build wealth yep
but would you say the same with single
stocks if someone's like i just want to
take a
few hundred bucks and kind of just like
play around stocks because it's fun the
problem is there's
what is you know it's okay to do it but
you just got to guard your mind and your
heart to say
why is that entertaining um
what is it what's happening inside of me
that makes
losing money entertaining
because that's what you're gonna do
you're gonna come home with rachel in
vegas you're gonna come home
without the money yeah yeah nine nine
times out of ten right and we're
that's why we're calling it
entertainment right because it's not a
legitimate investment vehicle
okay because it doesn't have any data to
back up people building wealth using it
now can p do people get rich quick
occasionally yeah but they almost
never keep it so in other words greedy
almost a greedy well here's an example
okay what if you said okay i'm going to
buy some lotto tickets because that's
fun
and i'm going to buy that out of my
entertainment
envelope instead of my investment
category okay uh
and you you know you're one of the rare
people that actually do that and you
emotionally protect yourself and you
spiritually protect your heart so that
you don't really think you're gonna win
and you hit a million dollars the
divorce rate among lotto winners
is tenfold the national average the
bankruptcy rate
within 10 years of hitting the lotto
is tenfold the national average 10x
now why is it that people hit the lotto
get bankrupt and and
divorce divorce more often than those
that don't
10 times more likely that's what's going
on inside you
yeah and the the very thing that caused
you to think that that was a valid
process
is the same thing is going to cause you
to be stupid again
and call it a valid process and so you
just
it's just dangerous territory it's thin
ice and so i mean
uh i i it is not entertaining to me
to lose money so i don't grasp the
concept personally
but i'm not such a snot that if you want
to go to vegas and lose some money to
crap tables i'm gonna be mad at you and
you call that entertainment with your
girlfriend trip or whatever okay
but the the what you really can never
allow to happen
is for your brain to start to tell
itself that this actually works
yep because if you ever start to tell
yourself this actually works
you are screwed you know you're in
trouble
so yeah single stocks included i mean
yeah here let me give you a statistic
interesting
wall street journal did this years ago
they took a monkey
and blindfolded it and handed it darts
and they had
all the stocks on the wall and the
blindfolded monkey threw darts and
picked
stocks wherever the dart hit they got
three of the top guys on wall street to
do what pick any single stock
or any three single stocks that they
wanted to pick to compete with the
blindfolded monkey's dart portfolio
[Laughter]
of the three top guys on real estate in
the world
on wall street the blindfolded monkey
beat two of them
he'd beat two of them now that's that's
how ludicrous the idea is is that you're
going to screw around with single stocks
and actually win okay
i know a lot about this subject i
intellectually
academically been licensing all this
stuff and i don't screw with it
because i know a lot about it right so
it you know
you can do it and call it fun and and
you can put it in your entertainment
envelope if you want to
and when people really got the jones for
a single stock they work for a company
the company's doing real well and they
want to
buy stock in their company i always tell
folks never have more than 10
of your net worth in single stocks with
a caveat that i don't buy single stocks
i don't own any single stocks not
one i had some given to me and i sold
them
you know i just no so if you want to do
it no more than 10
why because you're probably going to
lose it
and you're still going have ninety
percent of your wealth after you lose it
yeah yeah
or it's gonna or it's gonna underperform
right at a minimum
whatever your little day trade you know
i have a trading account with my broker
so i can talk about it when i go golfing
you know what a bunch of crap you know i
bought a little cracker barrel today
well i ate at cracker barrel today that
makes us equal oh my god
it's unbelievable you know so it's just
that that's what's going on it's just
dangerous as crud because of the way
your brain chemistry works
it's addictive i mean it's yeah the it's
all of it
it's exciting does it make you feel any
better that when i went to vegas on my
girls trip a few years ago i had an
envelope
with cash that was the amount of money i
was going to spend gambling and once
it was gone it was gonna be gone and i
wasn't worried about it and then i had
another envelope that anytime i won
i put it in the other envelope and then
when that ran out
by golly you came home came home with
your winnings my airline ticket
see what i mean this is this is this is
the case study of what i tell you the
problem is right now and then i got a
little bit more
you did the worst possible thing that
could have happened you have the idea
that you beat the system
i had an envelope made it better yeah
yeah all
that that makes it all okay as long as
you got an envelope
and you're right now okay obviously okay
it's all good so
have fun have fun boys and girls this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
four three
[Music]
[Music]
before we go to our lobby guest i was
just scanning through twitter something
i hardly ever do these days
but i thought after our little gamestop
discussion i would see and i went down
way before we even started doing
discussions so it's pretty funny
all the guys are saying stuff like
they're making uh hedge fund
manager jokes that how they're going to
pay off all their debt
after they've lost their money dave
ramsey's gonna tell you to sell your car
dave ramsey's gonna
it's really pretty funny it's cute very
cute and uh
and some idiots thought that i would
actually come out on the side of the
hedge fund managers why would i come out
on the side of hedge fund
managers i'm actually not on any of your
side i just spent 30 minutes telling you
not to do what any of you are doing
so but um it's still fun to watch the
whole drama
unfold and i'm glad some of you little
guys made money that's awesome i never
against somebody making money i'm just
against you doing it in a way that
causes you to lose it later and continue
in bad
systems kenneth and libby are with us in
the lobby
speaking of winning yeah right here on
the debt free
stage to do your debt free scream where
you guys live
amarillo texas all right welcome to
nashville
how much debt did you guys pay off uh we
paid off 105
694 dollars in 32 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time between 65
and 85 000. very cool good for you
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
hair stylist
and my husband is a supervisor for a
check distribution center in amarillo
cool
very good what kind of debt was this 106
000
it was a like three cars
and um 12 credit cards
and just personal loans just really
normal
just like three cars who you got a
teenager or something well we did
um we we did have a one at home
when we first started okay all right
very good
so what happened to you guys 32 months
ago that put you on this journey
well um at the beginning of 2017 um i
had a client give me the money makeover
book
and so i read it and i'm like oh
this is probably my answer because i did
have
we had 12 credit cards 10 of them were
mine and
um he didn't know about it until wow so
i read the book i told him about it and
he's like i don't think so
so i was like okay i'm gonna make the
change so i got another job
um like i said i'm a full i got full
client title um
full clientele and so i got a job for a
salon manager at a um
a place and so i was working both jobs
and then in october
our friends were hosting fpu at the
house
so i'm like okay i figured he's gonna do
it because it's our friends right well
he kicked and screamed until we got
there in our first class
and when you hit us with scripture dave
he was hooked
wow yes wow so what changed in you
so you i thought you were going to be
more the nerd but like the way you said
the numbers i was like you know every
single
dollar so i thought oh
but the spender with 10 credit cards you
were the one like okay we got to clean
this up so
so what hit in you scripture obviously i
know but like
what was it was it a level of um yeah
was it a level of conviction
or what what was that feeling uh it was
a feeling of
um not living scripturally you know we
were more being
to borrow a slave to the lender and we
retired to be enslaved to this system
here we want to be more godly
and more christian-like so we knew when
you first started talking to scripture
it just you know we had to make sure
that we were living that type of
lifestyle
so yeah god's lifestyle i mean as
christians we're supposed to
be like christ so to be like christ we
do his word we're obedient to his word
so that's powerful that's that's
interesting
so you were um kenneth you were like me
i guess you were probably just
suspicious that this whole thing was
like some kind of scam or something
yes sir i i would be that's how i am yes
i immediately
assume the worst i have the spiritual
gift of cynicism
yeah i just uh to me sometimes if it's
too good to be true yeah it usually
isn't
you know true so i was real skeptical
and then
as we were going through it there was
just times that the light bulb would
just hit
on you know especially we were talking
about the banks and their house was
bigger and i work at a print shop
and literally i could look out my window
and my work and i could see
you know the big old banks out there and
i realized i lived in a 40 000
home and i had debt and they lived in
these big old
12 20 story you know buildings and it
was just
it just all came it just clicked and i
realized i was serving
this world instead of helping the
kingdom of god wow
so at that point you guys left the fpu
class and so you got in the car and
you're driving home
and are you both just kind of game on at
that point like all right we're going to
change we're going to do something
different
yes ma'am yes our first budget meeting
when the everything came out the truth
came out and how much we really had
is when he's like okay well this is not
on it and he did he said this is not on
you this is on me because i am the
leader of the house so
we're going to do this together and
we've never looked back
we've um coordinated two two
um wow at our church
you guys are probably rock star
coordinators too this
we like to think i hope so we hope so
you know we want to be
an example we want to be the example for
those who do take it
they're going to cut you know i think
we're going to start a class on from
kenneth on how to be a husband
yeah he's pretty incredible dude that's
like that's pretty incredible
that's impressive awesome so libby so
you had some hidden
so tell talk to people out there because
this is a very real thing a lot of
people
do they hide their spending because they
don't want to confront and have the
conflict with their spouse they don't
want their spouse to judge them i mean
like that's that's a very normal
conversation sadly in america today
so what would you say to a wife or a
husband out there that's listening that
has hidden credit cards
they hide purchases from their spouse
what encouragement would you have to say
oh
come clean and come together and work as
a team yeah just
just that i mean get yourself a kenneth
first of all
but it's so much more freedom when when
your other spouse knows
that you know you do have all of this
hidden stuff or that you're you're
shopping and you shouldn't be shopping
and oh
that's new no i just haven't worn it
before you know just stuff like just
come clean it's so much free
jesus comes to set us free right so why
are we where are we
bounded up in chains yes so a lot of
people we talk to that go through
fpu or they work this plan and they get
out of debt they say on the other end
yeah we're debt free with no debt and
our marriage our marriage is even better
and we're like well it's not a marriage
class
right it's a money class but what so
talk about that aspect for you guys as a
married couple what did it do to your
marriage
i would say it strengthened our marriage
it it took away the division
you know the secrecy of it like for me
to step up and say hey
i'm the spiritual leader of the home
that was on me because
if i'm the leader of the home then i
should have known what was going on the
finances and she had a
her own business which you know was a
hair so we had two different bank
accounts but that
still wasn't any excuse not to be
engaged in that so as a husband
you know you need to learn to be more
engaged and have the open communication
so that when things did come up like
this it was easy to handle
and for me when we did the classes i
just told everybody it wasn't her fault
it was my fault
because i didn't take accountability of
what was going on in the home
it's amazing amazing you guys are
powerful that's so
gentle so strong uh very very powerful
very powerful well done so when you're
leading the class you paid off a hundred
and six thousand in 32 months i'm so
proud of y'all
well done uh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
this is impressive yeah like i said i
mean
to be christians we're supposed to be
christ-like so what does the lord say
about money what does the lord say about
debt you know we're not supposed to be
slaves to the lender we are supposed to
give and not you know
we don't need everything that we think
we need you know the best car is the
best
he wants us to have good things but not
where we go into debt
amen so this i mean being obedient to
the word
that that's the key for us yes we wanted
to be better christians
yes ma'am i do too after meeting them
we have a strong foundation our church
is awesome and he
our pastor actually wants to do um i
don't call it momentum anymore no church
church-wise
yeah he wants and so he is we we are in
the process
oh great for ramsey plus yeah yeah our
kids um called us
our my my youngest son has a wife and a
let's do that
all right 106 000 paid off in 32 months
making 65 to 85 kenneth and let me count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
well done you guys man they're powerful
wow what a neat couple so great oh
amazing
amazing yeah if you want to be them when
you grow up we'll help you
wow yeah way to go guys and leading
financial piece in ramsey plus still
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
four three
[Music]
so many many years ago i was invited to
be on the oprah winfrey show
back when she still had her show and it
was a big deal because if you got on
oprah
and she extended her scepter to you
and gave you the nod your book would
sell a million copies i mean it was she
had an
amazing power in the publishing world
for selling books
and so getting on there was like a dream
come true and so we worked for weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks
working with their
team and they laid out a 52-page script
and we were going to work with three
different couples
on three different money problems uh
on the show and of course i got with
them ahead of time and learned a lot
about their stuff and then i was to come
on the show and give them advice on the
particular situations
and you know it went pretty well through
the first two um
or through the first one and then the
the next one was a guy
his wife had hidden uh seventy eight
thousand dollars in student loan from
him
that he didn't know she had um
my contention was obviously it's bad for
her to lie and have have hidden and
deceived her husband no question about
that
no you should never deceive your spouse
that's not a thing
but i said also you know part of this is
on him
because he's not engaged enough in his
own household to know that 78
000 dollars had gone through your house
and you didn't know what happened
you know and um she was in charge of the
money
and he was just making money and so she
did whatever the flip she wanted
including this
and so it was in the script like and
dave says
you know and oprah reads that and she
goes off on me
she just she got pissed she's like
that is absolutely not right it is not
his fault she shouldn't have lied
and he delegated the handling of the
money to her and then she just
misbehaved
and i said well that that that is that's
a lot of that's true
but on the other hand in a marriage
you're supposed to be engaged enough in
your life to know what the flip's going
on
as the husband or the wife yeah either
one of you need to know what's going on
kenneth just talked about that that's
what made me think about it
and um and she just went on and on and
on and on and i said listen this is not
a joint venture
it's not a business it's a marriage yeah
and now you are one
well her audience clapped well then she
even got madder because they took my
side
it didn't go well it didn't i didn't
sell any books
because i i questioned mother nature
oprah's pretty powerful i'm not gonna
lie but no but and that's india and
it's amazing to me how many women i talk
to
long for their husbands to care they
want their husbands involved
they're like oh they how do i get my
husband on board or how do i how do i
get him to care how do i
have him start you know helping me pay
off debt right i mean and the husbands
say this about wives as well i mean
it's but i do hear that for women and so
there
is a call to you men out there your
husband's out there
kenneth man he's teaching class on well
just stepping in
and just stepping in and that's loving
your family so well
that both of you both of you have a say
it's not that one doesn't have the other
right you're a team in this you both
lock arms and you say okay we're in this
together
but oh when there is a level of unity
and i can speak as a woman when a
husband comes in
and says okay let's do this together
there there's just a safety there there
is
and so gentlemen it's a challenge to you
step in if you're not
step in because your wife probably longs
for it it's it's ex
it's exhausting and it's lonely if
you're doing it by yourself well
even if you're the one that's the
administrative one who's actually
probably going to do
most of the actual money work just to
emotionally
and spiritually carry the weight
together yes in your case
winston is the nerd he's the one that
runs the stuff just because it's his
nature and it's not your nature
um but um you know uh
you know another household might be a
different way and so you know
either way no one needs to be carrying
this stuff by themselves it's not fair
it's not efficient it's not practical
and it does not give you the result you
want
and to that point just to extend it to
clarify and that means it's the
emotional it's the conversations you're
in and esteem now who actually
writes out the bills or takes the bill
and takes out the checking account right
that doesn't matter yeah the logistical
side whoever wants to do it can do it
but the fact that we're making decisions
together we're talking about money
we have unified goals i mean all of that
agreeing on a budget
no nothing is hidden yep all of that a
lot of this is covered in
rachel's new book know yourself know
your money and you can get in there and
know
what your tendencies are what your
spouse's tendencies are and it gives you
a platform to have a
discussion and increase this
communication they were just a beautiful
couple oh they were wonderful yeah their
spirit was just incredible yep i mean
both of them
and wow just powerful all right
elizabeth is in huntsville hi elizabeth
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave and rachel thank y'all so much
for answering sure
how can we help um so
my father passed away in june of
2019 pretty suddenly and then he was an
only child and he took care of my
grandmother who
is widowed took care of pretty much all
of her finances
um and in the process of all of that
he kind of got himself into some
financial trouble himself
and was kind of um i hate to use the
word
feeling because she knew about it but
she didn't want to
say she knew about it using her money
because he was attached to her bank
accounts
um so he
kind of had that kind of ties into the
story but um
after he passed away um she was two
hours from us
so she kind of um was alone
um i've got two small children my sister
doesn't live here my brother's
a teenager so um she kind of
ended up with this caretaker
who we don't really know where she came
from
she's super sweet seems genuine
as good as gold
but my grandmother has a lot of money
and she
has this woman who kind of takes her
around takes her to her doctor's
appointment
how old is your girlfriend she is
in her late 70s and what's a lot of
money
i don't know how much 10 million a
hundred thousand
up to i would say between two and five
million
okay all right that's a lot of money i'm
just making sure i knew what that meant
okay yeah well and we so what are you
going to do about it
i was the executor of my father's estate
and so i kind of of course i wouldn't
wish that on my worst
enemy but somebody's got to do it
i have kind of talked talked to my
grandmother
like she has made comments you know
about
it being our inheritance and i hate to
think of it as my money i did not work
for that money
but that's not the point the point is
you don't want her to get messed over by
somebody who snaked their way into an
old lady's life
right and so i have she has actually
said something to me
about being the executor in passing
well i waited again until we were alone
and said so were you serious about that
and she said well yeah i would like for
you to help
such and such with with those
kinds of things so
i found out um that this elizabeth we're
running out of time you're going to get
to the point what's your question
i'm sorry what what do i need to how
should i approach her
like without making it seem like she's
making a terrible decision
number one number one grandma i don't
need any of your money
i'm just worried about you and i smell a
rat
i love you and i want to walk with you
and help you in any way i can
i think this lady may be okay but i also
am very very worried about her
having an undue influence over you and i
don't want you to get taken advantage of
i don't need any of your money you can
leave it all to a charity
you don't but i just don't want you to
be taken advantage of so how can i help
you
prevent that because granny i'm worried
about you
okay yeah that's not bad
no i mean i mean i think being open and
honest elizabeth and as straightforward
as possible in a loving way
is going to be effective because and and
see how she responds see what see what
she says
yeah i think people in your family are
classic
southern wonderful people like me
and uh we think being nice is
uh is necessary to get into heaven and
it's not
you're too that gum sweet you're gonna
have to get to the point
yeah you're too sweet you're trying to
make everybody happy and you're just
you're
it's just like sweet tea you're just
like sweet tea honey
you're just the nicest person and you
don't want to make anybody mad you don't
want anybody to be
have their feelings that's you that's me
that's me i'm the same way
i'm just the sweetest little thing
sweetest little i'm just the sweetest
little old thing
that's me sweetest now you guys get to
the point hurt somebody's feelings for
their own protection that's me
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us
john dr john deloney is my co-host today
we taking we are taking your calls about
your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five doctor john i was
listening to your uh podcast
uh-oh and uh listening to you take a uh
a call about a serious marriage
situation where the wife was having an
affair
and uh you're giving her husband some
advice on that and walking through it
and
you get into life questions like that
all the time and one of the things we
have discovered
obviously many years ago and we've got
you now here to help us address it is
that marriages
all can use a date night especially
right now an evening to come together
so we are announcing today a great date
night rachel cruz and dr john deloney
are going to be doing a money and
marriage
streaming edition the valentine's
edition the third time we've done this
so dr john deloney and rachel cruz money
and marriage
streaming live february the 12th
at 7 pm and i'm gonna guide you and your
spouse through an unforgettable evening
where you realign your goals on your
marriage learn healthy communication
and early bird passes for the money and
marriage livestream are on sale right
now
twenty dollars they won't last long so
earmark at twenty dollars on your
february budget
get over to dave ramsey dot com slash
events get your tickets again
money and marriage valentine's special
live streamed for 20 bucks february the
12th at 7 pm y'all been working on this
content i saw you downstairs working out
today
yeah and my favorite part is it's it's
jam-packed with
great information were all sitting
around with the content folks and rachel
this morning um all nodding our heads
some of us were taking notes on what
other people were
like that's a good idea right for our
own homes and
we were laughing so hard we can't
couldn't breathe and so this will be a
fun night
it's going to be a fun night it's going
to be a hard night of discussion night
but it's going to be a blast
yeah well you into it you and rachel uh
yeah that's right that just spells fun
right there i'm just saying that's
fun right we do laugh a lot right yeah
it's um y'all are trouble
you know trouble you're trouble looking
for a place to happen so
it's gonna be a lot of fun and you'll
learn a lot and it'll give you some
actual tools one of the things about a
ramsey event that i learned
way back with the overhead projector
when i first started speaking
um was that money and marriage
uh these difficult subjects um
spoonful of sugar makes the medicine go
down absolutely
the quote the great philosopher mary
poppins and um
so you got to have some laughter around
these subjects that have so much
shame and pain and
i don't know almost self-loathing
i don't know any couple on i don't know
any couple in my in my world
um who has not had to have a series of
tough conversations over the last year
whether it's financial what are we gonna
do
or whether it's man if i see you in this
part of the house again i'm going to set
you on fire right it's whatever it is
uh and some couples have come up with
time that was a little that was a little
weird that's very close right is that
you just opened up that may have been
you see a counselor
trust me yes um everyone's struggling
with it and here's the cool thing about
an event like this
is you're gonna be sitting on the couch
next to somebody that you care deeply
about
and we're gonna give you permission to
ask some questions that may be hard to
ask otherwise in your house
right so we're going to give you we're
going to we're going to shut the tape
we're going to throw the ball for you
that's right underhand pitch that's
right
set the table it'll be fun so yeah so
always ramsey events are a spoon full of
sugar so there's always going to be
humor
it's always going to be stories and
there's always two major goals one is we
want to lift you
yep uh and motivate you uh
and also we want to give you stone cold
steps of information to actually do
something here's the
i don't want to motivate you with
nothing to do no and i don't want to
tell you what to do without motivating
you right
so we got to get both things going and
every time any of us do a talk it's a
demand i put on the personalities that i
have put on myself since i started
because people that just do fluff and
they don't tell you what to do drive me
nuts and people tell you what to do and
put me to sleep
that's right with a root canal your
mother's 401k meeting
i don't want to do this either so it's
not who we are and so this money and
marriage event is going to be fun funny
uplifting and give you concrete things
to do and in the back end it's gonna be
hard right there's gonna be some things
you can talk to your spouse about it's
gonna be some
some challenges that we're gonna give to
you about your money about your marriage
about your
intimacy about your kids all that stuff
we're gonna we're gonna touch on it and
then we're gonna give you some concrete
steps to go make it better our third
annual valentine's edition of money and
marriage
streaming live to your home february the
12th
7 p.m central time rachel cruz dr john
delaney both ramsey personalities both
best-selling authors and uh
you can get early bird passes right now
for only twenty dollars
so jump on the jump online and get that
before the twenty dollar versions of
these tickets are gone
and uh go to daveramsey.com events and
you can learn more about this
it will be worth your evening february
the 12th to set you up for
valentine's weekend valentine's day
and um it's just the right thing to do
money and marriage it is
this rare one-two punch of the number
one cause
of divorce in north america day money
fights and money problems number one
things couples fight about is around
that
and it's you know as a coach counselor
marriage counselor pointed out one time
they're really not fighting about money
they're fighting about what it's doing
can i power one of the things i noticed
early on back in my practicum in grad
school when you're when you're finally
out there meeting with real clients
dave within two or three sessions folks
would tell me
everything about who they've loved who's
broken their heart childhood traumas
they could not to a person
get into a discussion about how much
debt they had they could not get into a
discussion about
money what their future looks like
tightened up and their
doesn't work let's go back to my old
boyfriends how about that right let's go
back to childhood trauma and it's just a
pain point that
we just so much shame around in our
culture and we've done such a great job
presenting these curated images of
ourselves that man once you get in there
and sit on a couch and hold somebody's
hand that you love
we got to get into we got to do this you
got to you know the the live stream is a
rare thing in that regard because if
you're sitting in an auditorium with
with 8 000 people
you know you can't really just elbow
your spouse to the point you break the
ribs when he says that
he's talking about you that's right but
uh yeah but you can do that on the couch
at home
yes yes but also you can't run and hide
gentlemen
and when you're in a room full of five
thousand people you can't all go to the
bathroom at the same time right
and there's gonna be some moments when
you're gonna
feel like i probably should go get some
more popcorn honey right so you're gonna
have to stay plugged in
and stay in there man and it's going to
be worth it i'm excited
money and marriage again the valentine's
day
edition the third time we've done this
our third annual special valentine's
edition
it is live streamed this year completely
and uh rachel cruz dr john deloney
uh it is february the 12th at 7 p.m
tickets are only 20 at daveramsey.com
make sure you jump out there and
get her done this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
do
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at chministries.org
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author
of the book redefining anxiety is my
co-host today
tom is with us in utah hi tom welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave yeah it's just a pleasure to
chat with you um i've
uh so just over the years i've
accumulated up to about
213 000 in debt and granted
most of that is about 163 000 of that is
just my mortgage and then
i've got 30 000 in a home equity loan
and 20 000 between credit cards um i
mean i've heard of your program
you know over the years but i figured i
knew how to run my finances better
here i am you know but um it's kind of
it's how i got to this stage was
basically you're just kind of living
slightly outside my means and just cut
it just kind of built over time
but my main question comes down to i'm
interested in your program i want to
start it
um but i do on the side over the past
few years i've just been
slowly day trading a little bit you know
and uh investing in little stocks in
there and i've actually built up quite a
bit i originally invested like
like 4 500 and okay about like 23 000 in
there
now and i just wanted to know what you
would do
with that whether you would just well my
question is
should would i should i just set that
aside and pretend it's not there and
just let it do its thing or should i
take that out and use it to
you know slam on some of these debts and
pay some of them off
and get rolling on that okay
well the the thing you've got to decide
is you have to finish
the decision that you've started and
then that will tell you what to do
and the decision you're making is are
you going to continue
uh to work the plan that you've been
working
um are you going to work some kind of
modified version of our plan which is
your new plan
or you're just going to do our plan and
and that's a decision you've got to make
and it's up to you
i mean there's there's no big shame in
it uh
you know the reason you're calling me is
because we have a track record of
helping tens of millions of people get
out of debt and into wealth
and then but the the but the things we
tell people to do
are uncomfortable and strange and
they work every time but they're
uncomfortable and strange and you feel
weird when i tell you to do them because
they're so perpendicular to the way
you've been thinking and living
and so that's what you've got to decide
i'll tell you what to do and then you
still got to go home and make that
decision okay
so in other words it's kind of like the
way i look at it is like
i remember one time several years ago i
looked down and there was this thing
growing on the front of me it was a
belly
and i hired a personal trainer to come
to my house i got a little gym in my
house
and my wife is in perfect physical
condition it's ridiculously wonderful
because she's my wife but simultaneously
shaming
and so um i mean zero body fat she's
ridiculous
and the guy's like giving me nutrition
advice and i'm like dude you're here to
work me out i don't really want your
nutrition advice
so and i go back upstairs and she goes
you're paying the guy and you're not
listening to him
he has a six-pack you have a keg
you gotta decide you know and so you
gotta i am you know
he's standing there a greek god and i'm
not
right and so i gotta decide if i'm gonna
do that or not and that's i'm
poking at you here dude but that's what
you gotta decide
because i'm your personal trainer and i
do this and i'm the best at it and
you're either gonna do this crap or not
so
having said all that i'm going to tell
you what to do and then you still got to
go decide whether you're going to do it
or not
i i don't do single stocks i don't do
day trading
and when people start our program we
take any money that is anywhere
that is not in a retirement account and
we pay off debt with it
immediately to become debt free so that
means i would pay off all your credit
card debt and a bunch of your home
equity loan with your day trade account
and i'd keep a thousand dollars set
aside as your starter emergency fund if
you have any other money i'm gonna throw
it at that home equity loan
and i'm gonna get it attacked as soon as
it's gone
with great focused intensity i'm gonna
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses that is not
in a trading account it's in a simple
savings account it's
not there to make money it's there to
protect you it's your rainy day fund
then i'm gonna start investing in good
growth stock mutual funds and baby step
four putting 15 of my income aside and
working it in that order that is the
shortest distance between where you are
and healthy wealthy and
you know enjoying your enjoying your new
millionaire status
the shortest distance is not day trading
there's no data points that says it is
just because you know well my cousin
made a bunch of money at the roulette
wheel in vegas well that doesn't matter
your cousin just got lucky once and
there's no data points that says playing
roulette in vegas is going to make you
rich
matter of fact it makes a casino rich
that's why their furniture is nicer than
yours
and so while they have a 28 million
dollar
uh glass sculpture hanging from the
ceiling when you walk into bellagio it's
bought on the back
you suckers yeah you you suckers bought
that they didn't
you know that's that's how that works
and so you know you guys got to decide
that
and what you're going to do at that
point and so i always feel like somebody
who's
that much in debt who's also
and we hear it all the time got a rental
house or i'm day trading
it's like turning every faucet on in
your house and plugging up
the the drain with a towel and then
heading on downstairs with a bucket
trying to bail the water out
you know as it's as it comes down it
doesn't come that's right
yeah um go turn the faucets off man stop
hemorrhaging money
with the debt yeah and then go close the
credit card account
swear off a debt and chop them up
have a plastic surgery party pay them
off
and you know i i went broke
tom that's how i learned this because i
i was
i was a nothing down real estate guy
and uh and it took me out i built a
house of cards because i got rich quick
i did get rich but i got rich quick and
you don't get to keep it when you get
rich quick it's
he who hastens to be rich
will not go unpunished and you could
have been this call
saying hey over two years i got this
much money man what should i do with it
yeah
i i i would have been i mean if i had
called into this show
at two years in right 26 years old i
would have said i have four million
dollars worth of real estate
i owe three million dollars on it a
bunch of it is in 90 day notes and i'm
making 250 000
a year what should i do and uh
and i would have been told to get out of
those dadgum 90 day notes because that
bank is going to chop your freaking head
off with those things
and i would have said oh no not me
because i've made
four million dollars worth of real
estate
bought it from nothing yeah i mean i
i've got a million dollar net worth
four million minus three million in debt
and i'm 26 years old why would i listen
i mean
it's something it can't happen to me
other end of that teeter-totter's got to
come down at some point right
and i'm not saying tom is saying all
that but but you're bro that's the way
your brain works
when you're in these situations and so
there's so many people out there and
this gamestop story today is just
fabulous for that
because it's these little day traders
are just they're so fun there's a bunch
of rebels
yep and they're they're punching holes
in the big fat cats on wall street just
knocking the crap out of them but if you
boys stay in that stock
it'll turn around when it comes back
down to what that company's really worth
you're gonna have taken a spanking right
so today would be your day to get out
and just call yourself lucky
right you had your fun you had you won
cause you think you got it figured out
now you think you got your angle now
and now you're now you're now you're b.a
you know
you can hit that dude and he'll stumble
then you better run because when he
turns around man
he's coming back for you yeah and we're
not talking we're talking about
life and math we're not talking about
the the fat cats on wall street
they don't they're gonna survive right
but um some real funny stuff going
around on twitter about the hedge fund
managers calling today ramsey show how
to get out of debt now
because they're deeply in debt that's
funny like so dave ramsey said soil car
you know
so i saw some great ones today about
being the
the hedge fund managers with their mbas
shaking their heads as they walked to
work as they got
defeated by mama underscore big guy 84
at hotmail.com like yeah he beat you
buddy
yeah today he did yeah that's right the
bottom line is they're both playing a
game that is not a long term play
that's right they're both playing a risk
game yeah and they're both going to get
their heads taken off and it feels good
you man you start at 4500 it's just like
you said it perfectly sitting at the
roulette wheel
you spin it and sometimes you get three
or four in a row and you start
sitting up taller acting like you know
how to spin the wheel you ask for
another drink you ask some people to
come around
and then the the casino is just counting
on you to keep that money right right
right there when rachel cruz was at the
crap
i've heard the rumors i've heard the
stories this is gonna go forever
she actually had the audacity to say in
another hour that she's good at rolling
dice oh my gosh
she said that out loud you're gonna need
to watch the money in marriage saying
we're gonna set it all straight that's
right
man this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same time financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option and the original
health cost sharing ministry for
christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
free
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five cheryl is in chicago hi
cheryl welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
good and hi hi dr john i guess we sit
next to you over there
so we're good hi good to talk to you
okay good
good yeah okay so i'm 48 years old and
i'm
a middle school math teacher i make 59
000
growth i'm recently divorced and just
finished
furnishing my house and i have i took
fpu last year through my church and i
have saved the thousand dollars for the
emergency fund
but i do have some debt um i have a
personal loan that was consolidated
credit cards and my divorce attorney
fees
um and i have um
a car loan and then i have 35 000
worth of student loans for my bachelor's
and my master's how much was the car
loan
um right now like my balance is about 15
17
000 okay and what is the uh the
consolidated loan
uh about 7 700. okay all right
so so my question is because i'm getting
up there in age
i'm kind of nervous about my retirement
i do have my teacher's pension
and then i will also be getting half of
the marital property of
my ex-husband's operators in labor's
pension we are married for 22 years
but i'm sure i need more and so my
question is
should i continue to do the baby steps
in order
or should i sort of try to do a couple
at the same time or jump around and make
sure that i have
sufficient retirement funds you're 48
yeah you're trying to say
pretty insulting that you think you're
up in age 160. okay
hey cheryl i'm sitting next to it i'm
sitting next to an old person
you are not sorry sorry oh
no i'm kidding you all right so here's
here's the thing
the most efficient way for you to build
wealth
is to get out of debt first so the baby
steps still work
now what the the fear that you've got of
not of of getting a late start on
retirement and and really wanting to
build that nest egg is a good
fear and then it's going to push you to
do great things
and push you to sacrifice to get the
debt cleared out
and so okay i see what you're saying
yeah so you got 57 000
you make 50. so um i mean i
i would make a plan with some extra
tutoring
and some other stuff um math tutoring
can you you can make 20. i do
i do yeah it's a little bit uh fickle
right now because of um
yeah you know there's people that commit
to it and then they pull out of it
because it's basically remote because
you can't
meet in person so that's been up and
down this whole school year but i'm
going to stack them up really high
because the good news about them being
remote is you don't have to drive
anywhere
so you can stack them back to back to
back to back to back and then if you got
one drop out it's not as big a deal
i'm going to work like a crazy person
and be done in two years
oh wow 20 20 25 26 000 28 000
a year out of your 50 which means you're
on beans and rice
rice and beans you're not going on
vacation there are no frills
because i'm worried about retirement i
want to get this out of the way
because if you don't have any payments
but a house payment you can save
aggressively for retirement can't you
well yeah um yeah so after well
right now i'm just renting a house well
i anything but the rental i mean i'm
just saying that
the point being that when you don't have
any payments
except housing you've got room in your
budget to save aggressively and build
your nest egg quickly and that's what
you need to do
so you go back to your financial piece
university materials
and uh i tell you what hold on i'll have
kelly pick up and we'll put you through
again you can go into ramsey plus and
and uh go through financial peace and
get just get up
get in that those groups that are on the
in the gr in ramsey plus
the financial peace groups and there's
some ask a coach
options in there too and you get some
people around you to encourage you
because you're
getting ready to engage in a very harsh
level of sacrifice for two years to set
yourself up
at 50 to begin saving aggressively for
retirement
and it's going to feel extra exhausting
because you're coming off the heartbreak
and the pain and the exhaustion of a
divorce yeah
and so you feel like uh now it's going
to lay down and no you just swim across
the
the channel and now it's time to keep
running because there's more lines on
that side
yep absolutely austin is with us austin
is in
portland oregon hey austin how are you
hey dave hey john uh i'm in some
desperate need here of some uncle dave
advice
i've got an hoa
for my town house that
we're voting on a special assessment and
it it's it's
up for vote um in the next week or two
and they're they're trying to charge
each uh each owner
twenty seven thousand dollars for
uh repairs for drywall dry rot
and mold um i'm at a little bit of a
loss
as to what to do or how to deal with
this i'm
skeptical of the honesty of hoa
i don't know the contractor obviously
i talked to the hoa the the the head guy
over there yesterday
and he told me my best bet would be to
try to contact my insurance
today and try to get special assessment
insurance
and they'll probably cover it that
sounds like
insurance fraud to me if i've ever heard
it and
it hasn't gone through yet but it's up
for vote
and i don't know if i need to hit the
campaign trail
and talk to my neighbors or
if there's anything i can do about this
well there's two problems um
one problem if it's all true and one
problem if it's not
and so there's you know you got if you
got the if the place is falling down
and you got dry rot and you got to fix
it if you don't fix it the whole car the
whole thing is going to go down in value
and you're going to lose your property
value
um and the fact that it's gone this far
without somebody starting repairs
before they got this far behind means
that they've mismanaged it
at a minimum so new hoa
officers and management company come on
board recently
uh it was i don't know how long ago it
was before i lived here
and i lived here three years okay no so
they just suddenly woke up and realized
the place is rotting down
this is so strange well there's been an
ongoing lawsuit
i think it's been going just on just
before i
i had uh moved in a few years back
lawsuit by who um
it was the lawsuit the hoa sued the
original contractor
um for negligence and they got
500 000 from that
but the bid is 1.7 million
the hoa also has 200 000 in reserves
that they tell me they can't legally use
for this
because it's not an uh a foreseeable
issue like a roof or
you know some kind of foreseeable
maintenance was this disclosed when you
bought the place they should have
disclosed to you we're in the middle of
a lawsuit
and like you would have a claim there
i was not told but
it i'm sure it may have been in in the
bottom line of the last page of some
paperwork that i signed you know i'm
gonna check i'm gonna change tactics
here let me tell you what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna sell this piece of crap and go
somewhere else
yeah you you this is clowns to the left
of me jokers to the right
you ain't gonna get out of this it's a
circus
either the place is rotting down and or
there's a crooked contractor involved
and or
an hoa that's mismanaging or
some combination of all this nothing in
this whole deal sounds like it's gonna i
mean if you get in there and
you spend you're gonna spend an enormous
amount of energy auditing
all of their books and auditing their
processes and making sure that they're
competent and that this contractor is
not the
brother-in-law of the manager of the hoa
and you know you're not getting screwed
somewhere there you're gonna spend an
amazing amount of energy
pushing back against the tide here um
only to end up with a fixed semi-rotted
townhouse after it's all said and done
so you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
sell it let them screw with it
these idiots let me run just run
and once they fix it you still got the
same people leading right yeah you're
still got it i mean
run they're gonna knock on your door
next month run
that's exactly what i would do and i
hate hoas
ugh this is the dave ramsey show
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake
your window blinds for free
free samples free shipping new promos
always use the magic word the promo code
ramsey all right today's question comes
from matthew in illinois
my sister is going through a divorce
she's asking my wife and i to lend her
money for a new house down payment
when the divorce finalizes she could pay
us back through joint assets she has
with her soon-to-be
ex i don't like lending family money and
friends money because it changes the
relationships
i was wondering how would you gently
tell her no
this one's hard dave
i'm pretty strong when it comes to these
boundaries i'm interested you've had
this question for 30 years
um rabbi daniel lapin
wrote the book thou shall prosper and
he has a great line in there when it
comes to
uh you know people asking for your time
as people asking for your money
his response in writing like a letter
for instance he's writing a letter
responses
um i would if i could but i can't
because my commitments
to this this and this are going to
prohibit me from being able to
attend this meeting whatever it is right
that kind of a thing
and so maybe that phrasing will help us
here a little bit
um and it might even be i won't
in this case this is my sister i'm gonna
look at her and say what if i could
but i won't i could but i won't
because i don't think you should right
buy a house right now
you're coming out of a divorce i think
you should rent for a little while
heal a little bit i think you're going
to make a wiser decision
a year even two years after the trauma
of the lost marriage is behind you a
little further
than you're going to make in the heat of
the moment and so i don't i don't want
to assist you in doing
something that i think is going to be
bad for you right and
when you if you know anything about how
the liquidation of joint assets
it's a mess it's never what you think
it's going to be on the back end of this
and i think you're right you can come
stay with us for a month come stay with
us for a few weeks no months long or not
or not but i'll pay for your hotel room
but um yeah i'm not loaning you money
uh and you're gonna at the end of the
day i wish there was an easier way to
say this matthew but you sit down and
tell your sister you love her
um and either you can't or
you won't i'm not gonna do this i love
you and i don't think you should do this
because i think it's it's unwise i think
you're going to make a much
better decision a year after this is all
over you'll have your own money to do it
then
and you won't be making a decision
during the worst week of your life
that's right and i want to walk all
through this with you i want to love you
as my sister yep and
not i'm your cheerleader here like yeah
put strain on yet another relationship
of somebody close to you in the hardest
moment in your life
yeah and she's not gonna hear it and
it's gonna be like i needed you when the
chips were down and you didn't come
through for me
and at some point you got to be okay
knowing you're doing the right thing for
the preservationist relationship long
term
yeah henry cloud says that when you set
a boundary with someone that doesn't
have one
they seldom react well that's right yeah
and here's the thing
she'll barge up against it try to knock
that boundary over see how firm it is
and then check you can become a travel
agent for guilt trips and tell her you
love her
tell her you love her she just she's
gonna she doesn't need someone else to
judge her that's hard
when you say i'm not judging you i'm
just no i'm telling you yeah but she's
gonna feel it right you're saying hey
you're
this this decision is a bad one i know
better than you she's gonna hear that
that way and i get that and it's hard
um but man i'm not gonna hand you
gasoline in the middle of a fire
and um here's some maps get burnt some
matches light yourself on fire yeah
you know and i gave you the matches so
now i i
if you'll slow down and make a better
decision i can help you more yeah
and it's it's not that you're dumb or
something like that it's just your
no one when they're in the middle of
extreme trauma makes great decisions
that's right
and if you think that divorce is not an
extreme trauma then
you it's one of the worst right one of
the worst we went through a good divorce
i always want to go oh so now we know
why you got divorced it's the lying
but i mean off the air you and i were
just talking about man when you are in
it
you won't think clearly your brain does
the mechanisms to take care of you so
you're not thinking clearly it just
wants you to run or fight
and that's when matthew you as her
brother can step in with some hard love
and some hard truth
and keep her from making a tough wrong
decision here in the middle of a
hurricane
kathy is with us in milwaukee hi kathy
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you and thanks so much for taking
my call today sure how can we hope you
can help
uh settle a disagreement that my husband
and i are having
yes i love you i've got the whistle and
i've got the uh
referee's shirt on i'm ready i love
these i'm i'm team uh i'm team you
and dave will take your husband let's go
all right
uh so we are we're very fortunate we are
debt free
i follow dave ramsey my husband i would
say is dave ramsey-ish
but we've managed to work together over
the years
we recently sold a business uh with a
sizable profit
and with a sizable profit come capital
gains tax
we have had much information from
friends
and others sharing their advice to us
one advice that my husband is
entertaining is that we would
take out a loan
from a financial institution that we
invest with
at three percent invest the entire
amount of our profit for a presumable
greater than three percent gain
and pay off the loan uh with the profit
over a series of about five years
i said i don't think that's a great idea
i do not want any debt
and he said well what do you think dave
would say i said let's call and find out
ooh kathy burr he doesn't he doesn't
really
know much about dave because you
completely you completely got him girl i
mean you snagged him
yeah that was tricky on your part that
you're sly
try i try how much how much is this
dadgum business
how much money did y'all get uh it was
multiple millions multiple millions
over 10 no no
okay still fair fairly nice day huh good
a very nice day yeah listen
um i'll tell you what i personally do
in these situations i pay my taxes
and take what's left over and i'll live
my life with it
investing it and giving it and enjoying
it and whatever else i'm gonna do with
it
okay so it's real simple there's not a
chance
under the sun dave ramsey's going to
tell you to go borrow the money
and i'm going to go further whoever this
investment company is is suggesting this
is suggesting it so that the level that
they could make more commission
because you're going to be investing
more because you borrowed money to not
pay your taxes
and um not only is there advice wrong
it's self-serving
and so i would i would not only pay my
taxes i would get a new investment
advisor
i love it i love it you validated
everything i said to him
kathy i can i can feel your smile from
milwaukee all the way to nashville
it's coming through the phone yeah
that's right
listen it's it's uh it's a fool's errand
i mean to run around borrowing money in
order to invest
and essentially that's what we're doing
here in this discussion
are what's being suggested to you and
it's a fool's errand to listen to
uh friends who have never had a
multi-million dollar liquidation event
where they had that money laying in the
middle of their kitchen table like you
do
so you need i mean i've had this happen
i i've made that kind of money on a
transaction
and i'm sitting there looking at the
taxes and
so i haven't so tell me that's that's
got to sting right oh god
no it doesn't stink like i'm talking
about multiple days it takes me to get
over being pissed off having to send a
check that size
to those idiots in washington dc hey man
it melts my brain down
yeah yeah so now you just got personal
dr john and now we're going to do a
counseling session
i could for those of you not listening
the whole room just got real
hot real hot but i can't i mean you
think about it
let's just say they got four million
dollars all right that means they're
gonna be sending
eight hundred thousand dollars more
money they've ever seen in their life
they're about to write a check
their freaking money because they ran
that business
not some toadstool in washington dc
that's right
god so madney but the rich ought to pay
more in taxes oh
shut up way to go kathy now you got me
in trouble
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional
about your character you can have money
and a career
you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five kelly starts this hour in
colorado springs hi kelly how are you
hi dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up in your world
well uh my question comes around the
insurance the term life insurance
um my husband and i went through the
nerve to
get insurance and i did not
get approval for entering
and so i'm wondering what is the
like what is your recommendation going
forward i had cancer in 2017
um and lost a brother at 29
and my mom has a six years since he's
probably been there mid 40s
so you know health wise you know i know
that we're kind of
i'm risky but what is your
recommendation
the pacemaker and your mom is not the
deal breaker it's the cancer from 17.
and the further you get away from that
with a clean bill of health
the more insurable you'll become so your
journey
with xander is not over you just got
your first you just got your first no
and uh circle back with them and ask
them
ask them to check with the underwriter
and find out at what point
they would look at your situation
because they can insure
past cancer now maybe not since 17 but
maybe it's five years instead of three
years
or whatever okay so you we need to learn
that as a guideline number one
uh number two the only way you're going
to get insurance is where there's no
medical
involved meaning you don't have to sign
anything or
make any statements about health and
those are you those are called
guaranteed
issue policies uh
and they're usually small policies
and they are usually uh about five
to ten times more expensive than regular
term insurance
and so the where you have seen them is
like if you've ever seen
like when you open up a checking account
the bank they'll send you a thing or
your mortgage company will send you a
thing that says you can buy mortgage
insurance
on to pay off your mortgage if you die
those are typically guaranteed
issue policies uh that's one of the
larger ones you could buy
and you can go get that one if you've
got a mortgage um
which would be really helpful yeah you
can probably get that call your mortgage
company and ask them if they sell
mortgage life because they love to sell
it they make a lot of money on it it's
five to ten times too expensive
but it's a way to get your mortgage paid
off in the meantime and you can cancel
it later you don't have to keep it
forever
if you become qualified you know two or
three years from now you
get a full regular xander term insurance
policy that's less expensive you can
cancel this crap
but you've seen it with your checking
account ten thousand dollars insurance
you can just pick it up
sometimes even on the back of a magazine
or sometimes an association you belong
to with your
professional career we'll send you
something you know and it's just
it's a twenty thousand dollar policy a
thirty thousand dollar policy ten
thousand
policy sometimes people will get three
or four of those kind of stack them up
it's an inefficient way an expensive way
to buy insurance
but at least you've got some meantime
you're getting out of debt you're piling
up cash
and reaching towards self-insurance so
that if something happened to you you
wouldn't actually need any insurance
because uh the kids are grown and gone
there's a pile of cash and no debt
then he'd be okay without your income uh
but i
the mortgage life is probably the
biggest chunk you could knock out
and and then just stay in the game
don't just say well i can never get life
insurance because i once had cancer
that's not true
it's just that your uh
cancer-free date is too recent
because you know basically we all know
that life insurance is
priced or issued based on probability of
death so as you get older it's more
expensive you're more likely to die if
you're
60 than if you're 40. statistically
speaking
and same thing if you've had cancer than
if you hadn't had cancer and
so uh when you do get it it's going to
be
double what regular term is but
but it'll still be less than the other
insurance i'm recommending right now
so what is your so sheila and i we
redid our wills over christmas um we as
a part of just our annual planning and
and discussions and she's transitioned
in the last couple years to
stay at home for a season instead of
working and
what's your recommendation for like a
stay-at-home mom
or a stay-at-home dad when it comes to
life insurance
in a middle to upper income family i put
400 on them
okay uh with the idea being that it
would create thirty to forty thousand
dollars worth of income off of that much
invested
uh okay to hire mary poppins okay
because we gotta hire mary poppins
if something happens to mama right and
um and you know in other words we're
in a sense we're putting a an economic
value on a stay-at-home mom
right right what it would take to
replace the duties that she has
driver tudor maid
chief cook and bottle washer chef yep um
and i'm i'm
in a position where i mean y'all
y'all would walk through that season if
something happened to sheila tomorrow
you'll walk through that season with me
but there's
millions of of men or women who'd have
to go to work on monday yeah right i got
i got to be there right or i'm working
on the clock or something so every
moment i stay home
so that's good that's good advice i i
didn't know what the number would be
yeah and you know if
let's say your household income uh say
let's say we've got a stay-at-home mom
the husband makes 35 000. okay well
average household income in america is
59.
okay so he this is a lower income right
a lower below average
okay then you probably put 250 on her
because you would you would
have a different uh
level of uh not to say she's not as
valuable at home as someone else but
you would just expect a different level
of uh service
and care from the people that you hired
to come into your home okay
it's that kind of situation so uh plus
i'm trying to not spend so that gun much
money
on life insurance you know if i can
that's the idea
but yeah so typically folks we tell you
to have 10 to 12 times your income on
you
so if you make thousand dollars a year
uh either one of you uh if you had
ten times that'd be a half million
twelve times be six hundred thousand
and so if something happens you get the
spouse has six hundred thousand to
invest if they invest that
at ten percent for round numbers that's
sixty thousand dollars
and so you're making 50 you got you know
so you don't buy too much you have to
sleep with one eye open right
but but the uh uh but but you know you
want to have
enough invested that without touching
that amount
the income off of it replaces the income
of the one who died
i love it and that way the family can go
on
and uh it changes everything and
the most mind-blowing
jerking stories over 30 years of doing
this are not
65 year olds who died it's
27 year olds 35 32 year olds
with a brand new baby and
dave i've looked at those folks in the
eye they got a million dollars
or they don't yep and because of the
cost of a pizza that's right
a month it's they ask you that question
term life insurance from xander is about
as
noble a product as i know of
is you know it's really important it's a
safe place to land man yeah
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
in 2021 we are hitting reset
almost a half million of you have now
watched the reset event that was done a
couple of weeks ago over in oklahoma
city with
chris hogan rachel cruz doc uh pastor
craig crochell
and me and uh you can go watch it at
daveramsey.com if you want
it's out there we still got it sitting
there i think it's still sitting there
and with our money reset bundle it's
easier than ever to create
new habits that'll change everything and
you get a six month
membership to ramsey plus our best
sellers
know yourself know your money rachel's
new book my book the total money
makeover sold eight million copies a
couple people read that one
and here's the kicker every ramsay plus
membership now includes
free federal classic
e-file for your taxes through ramsey
smart tax
whoa ramsay plus members get free
ramsey smart tax to file your taxes i'm
using that
this year for my family boom there you
go you can get your money
and get your taxes right it's 167 dollar
value
this bundle all this stuff bundled
together the books the smart tax the
whole thing
ramsay plus 85 for six months wow
uh decide on a total money makeover
reset right now go to
moneyresetbundle.com money
reset bundle dot com
167 value half off at 85 bucks there you
go
christina is with us in nebraska hi
christina how are you
doing great thank you so much for taking
my call my pleasure how can we help
um so my husband and i are finishing up
baby step three on february 10th
and um i've been listening to a lot of
videos with you and chris hogan
talking about how you kind of take your
foot off the gas on baby steps four
through
six but i don't really feel like
mentally i've changed with my
spending habits and everything i'm an
emotional center and
even though i was able to have
self-control through your baby step
one two and three i don't feel like i've
changed much so
how do i take my foot off the gas but
kind of keep
focus and keep my head in the game of
of you know really smart question
and you've done really well how much
debt have you paid off
we paid off thirty two thousand eight
hundred and how long did it take you
ten and a half months how much ten and a
half months ten and a half months you've
been working
on almost a year all right and you said
we so you're married
uh correct and and we're finishing up
baby step three so it's actually been
uh two and a half years okay all right
okay good
and so you've got each other holding
each other accountable
and you're are you doing your written
budget i bet you are
yes um i'm using every dollar app and
okay he's using
uh microsoft money but if
okay but the two of you have a game plan
that both of you are aware of
and you're holding yourself and each
other accountable for sticking to the
game plan that we lay down on paper
right
correct him more so he's he's the favor
and i'm defender so him
him more so he keeps those in the game
for now okay
so christina i i and dave you can
correct me if i'm wrong here
christina i am not a person who can take
my foot off the gas
and i've got to put or you can't sprint
forever so let me say it this way
i have to have uh boundaries that i set
up in my life
because i'm like you i get fired up
about something
you know i need to go buy a new thing of
whatever i want to make sure if the
apocalypse happens that we're covered
so my wife and i have some agreements i
get cash i'm still pretty old school
when it comes to that i've got cash
um and we both use that every dollar app
we've got some things
that set up for me just because i know
i'm impulsive
and sometimes i'm i'm in my 40s now
fighting the impulsivity gets exhausting
so i set up boundaries that make it
impossible for me
taking your foot off the gas does not
mean
you go back to your old ways all it
means it doesn't mean you don't continue
to do a budget and it doesn't mean you
don't stick to it
and you go out to dinner right it
doesn't mean that you uh
aren't accountable to your husband he's
not accountable to you for the plan
all it means is the level of sacrifice
is lightened
the intensity of beans and rice rice and
beans no vacations no eating out
and no buying anything is lightened up
and you give yourself
permission to have a little bit of
wiggle room now
in the budget to accom to accomplish
some of the things
now that you've got the emergency fund
and now that you've got the other
i think it would be really helpful for
you all to get on the same budgeting
system i think it's a mistake that
you're not
okay because i think the two of you then
are going to get
more in sync you're sort of in sync like
you build the thing out
and then you you you know you you
combine them but then you walk back off
into two different rooms and run your
lives
and that leaves you vulnerable to your
spending habit
and he looks like the hero to his
savings habit and
i think you guys i think you're in his
life so he has more fun
that's why the spender's there and and
he's in your life so you have more to
eat and you have electricity right
yes and i think you guys this this
patchwork thing where you you you know
once a month you sit down together and
you combine your thing and then you walk
off into each of you do your own thing
i think that's leaving you vulnerable
and i think that's part
of where your fear is coming from is
because you're only having to deal with
you
right and but when you're both on every
dollar together and you both have it on
your phone
and you both know where everything's
going and every time a debit card is
swiped it shows up ding ding right there
where to hide man and um it's all just
full disclosure
full transparency it's either on the
plan it's not on the plan
and it's either what we agreed to or not
i can go buy you know if there's money
in there for clothing and you go buy
some clothing it shows up and that's
fine because it was in the plan
if there's money in there for food you
go buy some food and it shows up in
there that's fine
uh but we're not gonna just go off some
off the radar and buy something to
prepare for the zombie apocalypse or
something rachel talks about that in her
book
despite being a best-selling author and
talking about this for years and years
she still has a tendency to want to go
spin some stuff right
so i think that you allocate for that
you can do it that's exactly right but
you just do it in full disclosure and as
a part of a whole
right and i think i'm hearing christina
say i got to the end of this and i was
hoping all of
this all of my innate
um default settings were just going to
go away and be healed by knowing
debt-free no they're not you're going to
sleep deeper right not but
you know i'm a spender but now i spend
on purpose into this part of an overall
plan
that doesn't bring destruction to my
house right that's you know
right and if you say i'm a saver that's
great you save on purpose
while still allocating some money for
your family to actually have shoes for
life right that's right
yes you know not another roll of duct
tape exactly that's it that kind of
stuff you
cheapskate you know so you know that
kind of you know so those these are
tendencies rachel talks about the
tendencies
and uh either extreme on the tendency is
where it's toxic
it's not it's not you're right if you're
a spender you're wrong if you're a
spender you're right if you're saved or
you're wrong if you're a saver that's
not the point
and so the uh the whole idea then is
laid out so
i think if you guys will start working
together on one system
and have like there's more touch points
through the month
where more two sets of eyes are on
everything that's happening all month
uh then he's gonna get the benefit of
you
causing you all to have a higher quality
lifestyle
with your spending tendency and you're
gonna get the benefit of the stability
of his savings
tendency and larry burkett used to if
two people just like get married one of
you is unnecessary
so opposites should attract they do
attract and they should
and christina needs to not beat herself
up for
being a spender for right for how proud
to spend some stress in her life and
then reaching and then
that's when you've got a plan that's
when you've got accountability that's
you got someone else in your life y'all
got a routine together
and don't beat yourself up for it right
yeah it's not you're not broken
christina
yeah craig rochelle said the other night
he said just say no i'm in training
i like that no i'm in training can't do
that i'm in training
and uh it changes the vernacular i mean
when you change just the words it
changes the way you feel about it i
can't do that i'm in training yeah
i got a marathon i got to train it's
inconsistent with my goals yeah i like
that you know
and uh that the the saver and the
spender can both do that that's right
those are that's a verbage you can use
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author
is my co-host today carlos and claudia
are with us in el paso texas hey guys i
see on my screen you're debt free
congratulations
thank you yes we are we're so excited
how much have you paid off well we
paid off our final debt which was our
mortgage
eight thousand and eight months
yes talking to weird people
no debt no mortgage no nothing
that's right and how long did it take
you said forty eight thousand and what
eight months eight months on your range
of income during that time
we started at a hundred thousand
combined but we're up to 150 now
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
um i'm a nurse and i'm i'm a public
relations specialist
excellent good for you guys so well done
so how old are you two i just turned 50
just celebrated the big 50. and i'm 47
and you have a paid for house yes sir
that feels weird doesn't it
it feels awesome yeah
i'm not gonna lie it's awesome i'm so
proud of you guys
what's this what's the house worth about
250
000. boom boom just like that wow
i love it man i love it what inspired
you all to do this starting eight months
ago
well we were very gazelle intense dave
steps one through five but for some
reason we went more toward a speed
with our mortgage we were still sending
double payments
uh we refinanced our 30-year loan to a
10-year
five years into the loan because we
realized we had made a mistake
uh but then we got a sudden run from the
cheetah fever
in the past eight months so we were
sending thousands a month
i think our final payment was like 18 or
19 000.
good lord there's nothing like a nurse
coming home every day saying we should
probably pick this one up carlos
let's do that right correct yeah a
little cove had a little covered scare
drive some of this well you know we
um my job status didn't change obviously
there was a lot of work for me but um we
decided you know what if this is if
we're not going to do it now
why not let's just go for it so you know
carlos picked up
actually a part-time job at fedex
working nights and working in the
weekends and saturdays
and so of course i mean i was going to
be on board with that so we just
went with it you just jacked up and went
wow
we tightened the budget started eating
rice and beans beans
and rice and we got real aggressive with
it
so while other people are wandering
around in the street like zombie
apocalypse right now
with the coveted stuff going on you guys
took extra jobs and worked more
and paid off your house in the middle of
a pandemic
yes correct and i see two kids in the
picture here how old are they
they are 22 and 20 years old and they
are
fpu graduates they are debt free
they have emergency fund they're saving
for retirement
and they're going to graduate without a
single debt of uh
college debt they're seniors already in
in college
you're amazing wow wow are you guys the
first ones in your family
are you the first generation to do this
yes sir yeah
a pastor actually gave us your
book uh the total money makeover as a
housewarming gift
greatest gift he could have ever given
us wow wow
that's so very neat yes well i'm proud
of you guys what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of that is
well we coordinate uh fpu at our church
which is hope city in el paso texas they
saw how
aggressive we were with our debt so they
said you guys should be coordinated
at our church and so we tell the the the
students that go through the class with
us
is do the little part and god's gonna
reward and bless the rest the bible says
that
you know you be faithful with a little
bit and i'll take care of the rest
amen and we've seen it with our student
you know the people that go through the
class with us
they apply for jobs and they get not
just one but
two or three extra side gigs so we've
seen
the blessing time and time again in
their lives wow so that's the lesson
we've learned
excellent so what was the hardest part
of this for you guys
um actually for me i'm a lot like
sharing your wife like i'd rather just
have the money sitting there
kind of a security thing so for me the
hardest thing was
applying it appropriately applying our
savings appropriately which was to pay
off our debt
so that was a challenge for me but thank
god for my hubby here that encouraged me
to
to follow the recommendations as as they
are
yeah wow oh wow
well done you guys so proud of you we
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
every day millionaires without a doubt
you are on track to be that
maybe the first in your lineage to do
that as well and i'm so proud of you
guys very well done
all right carlos and claudia house and
everything baby
whoa 48 000 in eight months making 100
to 150
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Music]
yeah so awesome so
awesome awesome so awesome
so you're out there
listening to those two with a paid-for
home
why not you two 20 year old kids
that have no paid for everything
everything's paid for college is paid
for everything's paid for they're
already retirement they've already got
emergency funds
great place to go when you're broke to
work they're going to be able to put you
in a real nice home when the
time comes right wow
why not you yeah you're riding along the
interstate right this second listening
to this
yeah you it's your turn you
can it's your turn people do it all the
time and
and people that aren't as pretty or as
smart as you are
man can you imagine being a pr executive
your wife's exhausted after
you know coming home from being a nurse
every day and you look at each other and
say
let's do it i'm going to fedex i'm going
to fedex and
it's going i'm going to get home for my
pr job take off this tie i'm going to
put on that
that little uniform they have let me get
the truck and i'm going to do it
until i can't move my arms and legs i'm
going to fall asleep i'm going to do it
on saturday i'm going to do it on sunday
and then i'm going to get up and do my
pr job again work like no one else and
now what you do
you know like no one else you work when
you want to you know what he's doing
tonight
those feet are going to be propped up
anything he wants
wow that's how you do it so cool yeah
it's what it'd be like if you had no
credit cards or medical bills or student
loans or car
payments and you'd feel completely
different and um
we're gonna help you the ramsey plus
money reset
is all right there we're gonna walk with
you day by day and show you exactly what
to do for the first 90 days because
there's nothing
no one ever regrets a fast start
all in pay off your debts fast finally
saving for emergencies
the ramsey plus daily small
wins with your money add up to really
big ones
and we're going to show you exactly what
to do with financial peace university in
there
i'm going to show you exactly what to do
with the every dollar budget in there
we're going to show you exactly what to
do with the baby steps tracker the asca
coach the communities that you're in
this is a massive movement
and it is um it's changing everything so
you can just decide that's all they did
they just decided
and you can go all in for 90 days and
take control of your money
make today day one you can do a
free trial at ramsey plus just go to
daveramsey.com
reset do the free trial just get in
there and you can see all the stuff i'm
talking about it's unbelievably robust
it's high quality
you're going to be going where has this
been
well now that you've decided things like
this
are going to show up all around you but
you have to decide
you have to decide and you have to
decide you can do it just like
carlos and claudia did it and somebody
right now is driving
and you're thinking i think dave's
talking to me he is he's talking
to you you go home and have this hard
conversation with your husband with your
wife
your girlfriend boyfriend decide dave
ramsey dot com slash reset for the free
trial
do it this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first timothy 6
12 fight the good fight
of the faith take hold of the eternal
life
to which you were called and about which
you made
the good confession in the presence of
many witnesses
jennifer granholm said sometimes
leadership is planting trees
under whose shade you'll never sit
that's one of my favorite quotes in the
whole wide world i think
all of us are in a season right now the
country needs us to
be about planting seeds plant some trees
of fruit we will never eat
we will never sit down for our grandkids
man but yeah i love that
i was actually on a flight with a guy
who's
um people that are uh
fifth generation fourth generation
wealthy people
intrigue me because there's so few of
them right most of the wealthy people in
our country are first generation wealthy
and um so we're riding along and of
course i'm reading
a cia spy novel right
and this friend of mine who is um now
he's
these days he's at like 80 years old he
just turned 80 as a matter of fact
um has a phd in economics from cambridge
and he's reading a book on
um a math formula
a math problem that's never been solved
so i'm reading a spy novel this is like
i got a comic book right
this guy's got this dave's coloring this
just said yeah this just sets up the
dadgum thing right here
he's got colors he so finally he puts
his book down he says so so
ramsay what are you what are you
investing in i said well i buy
mutual funds and i did that i said what
are you investing in
and he said well that's just so that's
just so
nuvarish i mean that's just new rich
what you're doing you're just new rich
so he's basically patting you on the
head right yeah yeah well i mean has
been the entire
thing is the way he walks while he talks
what he reads i mean everything's pat me
on that the whole thing is
it's ridiculous but i'm just so
intrigued with a guy because he grew up
wealthy his
dad his grandpa was wealthy his great
his great grandpa was wealthy i mean
he's been wealthy a long time and so
he's he can call me that because it's
true
i'm wealthy but i'm first generation
right and so it's accurate and i've got
a different mindset than he has and he's
his point was he said
when you grow up like we like i do he
goes you think about
things generationally always and he said
i just bought six thousand acres in
kentucky and we just planted uh a
million and a half countries on them
wow so he's he's yeah he says you're 80.
yeah and he said yeah you know how much
of a labor a lumber shortage there's
going to be
in in 100 years in america and you know
how wealthy
my great-grandkids are going to be off
of that one decision wow
in addition to the other family wealth
about for that one decision so he's
he's anticipating a lumber shortage a
hundred years from now and he's 80.
right and putting little bitty pine
trees in the ground yeah
a million of them on six thousand acres
right and it's like
that is that's legit fascinating
planting
that's fascinating to me planting trees
the point is you think differently
about money it causes you to do things
differently but i think you can also do
that with character right
absolutely i'm gonna say this in this
way i'm gonna model this for my son
and one day our grandkids are going to
live differently yeah
we can change your family tree in terms
of behaviors yeah
absolutely alexandra is with us in
hartford connecticut hey alexander how
are you
hey dave i'm good thank you how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
um so um i have um kind of a decision
that i'm facing so
uh basically my husband and i have made
some poor choices over two years
in terms of like financial decisions and
then
pandemic hit and we both lost our jobs
since then we've recovered
and we kind of had a very hard
conversation about
like how to make us not um so
vulnerable again because we almost lost
our house and we have two kids
uh so i started on your program and i'm
using
every dollar app as of early october
last year uh and we were managed to kind
of get through
seventeen thousand three hundred and
forty two dollars worth of debt
good so we have no more credit card debt
there is no car debt anymore
medical bills are paid for
yeah we've been very aggressive so we
haven't really been doing much like we
haven't been on vacation we haven't gone
out or um we've gone out once but
um so how long did it take you to pay
off 17 000
um so with the first payments we started
making mid-october
um since october so in four months you
did seventeen thousand dollars
yes we did yeah from both being
unemployed we're about to lose our house
where our baby's gonna sleep too now we
have no credit card debt no car debt no
medical debt
yes sir it's incredible what's your
household income
um so we went back back to work um my
husband went back to work at the end of
september i went back to work
at the end of november yeah but what's
your household income a year now
right now it's 210 000 yay
okay good all right
yeah so we are um we ended up kind of
like going through all of our accounts
and we found out that we were behind on
tax payments but we have some bad
back taxes which we are tackling this
month and it's going to be done
um but i just have a little bit of
trouble planning for
kind of going forward so we have
um both of the jobs offer
us 401k for retirement with a three
percent match
um but at the same time we also want to
kind of
continue being very aggressive in the
way that we tackle
debt um and i um sort of and we also
have student loans
oh how much are your student loans
together it's 150 000 between me and my
husband
okay well you got a ways to go then you
just got to finish those up
yeah i just don't know like if we should
invest in our retirement
and pay no no
you said you're going to follow the plan
crush everything you've been doing has
been following the plan
and then you almost fell off the wagon
just now and we grabbed your hand don't
fall off the wagon
remember you were smart and then the
pandemic hit and then you realized we're
not smart let's get a plan and then you
got a plan and now you're starting to
get too smart again
go back to the plan well it it just
feels like
if we don't uh because our our company
offers 401k it just feels like we're
we're going to be missing alexandria
it's time to get rid of your student
loans
okay they're gonna be there the rest of
your freaking life if you keep talking
like this
okay so we should we should probably so
we should just opt out of the company
for one game yes you should opt out you
should stop that do you have any money
in savings
um we first uh got our like the first
savings badge
we did based on your plan which is one
thousand dollars in cash we set it aside
but this is the first month that we've
done it
okay and you do you have any other money
that is not in a retirement account
no okay all right so you make two
hundred thousand dollars a year
and you have been averaging about
four thousand dollars a month as you've
gotten this jet off the ground and now
you're gonna start averaging more than
that
because you need to be putting a hundred
thousand dollars a year i want you to be
done with this
these student loans in 18 months
okay that's 5 dollars a month
okay yeah that's still like super
aggressive and i feel like we're just
like
we're at home and we're we aren't doing
much um
and i kind of feel like i want to save
some
money for retirement how old are you my
kids into activity
um i'm 31. okay in 18 months
you're not gonna ever have a student
loan again
or you're gonna keep arguing with me
which you've been doing for five minutes
about investing in your stupid 401k
you need to finish this you need to
finish this
you need to finish this 18 more months
is not going to mean
that you don't retire wealthy because
you didn't start your 401k to 33 instead
of
31. crap a year ago you weren't doing
anything in your 401k anyway
and you were broke and deeply in debt
remember
remember how dumb and how bad
don't do it again 18 months
you can do this and quit arguing with me
about your stupid 401k
if you want your kids to have activities
that's fine go be with them
well that's fine you can have that kids
can have activities you make 200 000
a year i'm just putting 60 000 of that
that's all that's it 5 000 a month
you can do this she can do it man but
david's hard i'm tired
do it do it do it do it don't argue with
the thing don't argue with what
millions of people have used at work
don't argue with it
quit fixing a plan that ain't broke
[Music]
thanks james childs and kelly in the
booth great show today john
well done we'll be back with you guys
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you